as a director you have even a tougher
road than as a screenwriter because you
can't just sit by yourself and create
something and show it to somebody and be
unimpressed them you have to be able to
do what you say you can do and for a
director that means putting together a
lot of people and even for a cheap film
a lot of money relatively speaking and a
lot of time I mean making a feature film
is a is an investment of six months to
two years out of your life and during
that time you have to figure out how to
live - so that's you know that's a
harder road to hoe so to speak and
somehow you have to find a way to do
that because just telling somebody you
have a great idea just describing it to
them even you know if you're a good
artist if you can draw that that will
help a lot because you can do your own
storyboards you can maybe even do them
in color you can do a graphic novel a
comic book even if it doesn't get
published you can put it in front of
somebody and say here this is what my
movie would be and that can help and if
it's really great if it's really cool
maybe they'll take a chance on you more
likely they'll say that's really cool
we're gonna buy the rights from this and
we'll hire somebody else to make it so
going out and finding a way to make a
feature and finding a way to make a
feature that's good on whatever you're
able to raise so don't go out and raise
you know $50,000 and make star wars
because it's gonna look like crap it's
gonna look you know like nevermind what
it's going to look like but
find a subject matter that you can do
well on whatever amount of money you're
able to put together and if it means two
people sitting in a room talking then
write and then create the most amazing
interesting wonderful two people sitting
in a room talking film you can do
you